hello this is
and i will be presenting on the topic of
analysis of alzheimer's variant in
embryonic stem cell derived microbial
cells
so
first of all the basics about the
alzheimer's disease
it's a brain degenerative disorder
of
unknown etiology and it is most common
form of dementia that usually
starts when
a man is in its late middle age or an
old age
which also results in memory loss and
disruptive thinking and change in
personality mode etc
now these
degeneration of brain neurons especially
happens in the cortex region the
cerebral cortex region and preference
of neurofibrillary tangles
now
the
alzheimer's disorder is
like not very well studied here and
have
impacted different
you know
types of diseases
when we look into the genetic factor
which contributes for
alzheimer's disorder there are various
cell types which we study like
astrocytes and microglial cells are very
crucial to study
and
we have done a genome wide association
study
which have identified numerous
polymorphism
light
which elevates alzheimer's disorder
conditions
and causes a high risk of getting
alzheimer's disorder
now
the study has been done
by a group of scientists and they have
published their data set
with the accession ideas given in the
slide
and in that accession number they have
taken several samples of some of the
alzheimer's disorder variants
which are present on the loci city 33 in
p5t
sorel one and trem two
so what are these they are basically
transmembranal proteins or some sort of
membrane related uh
yeah components which perform different
functions and are active for
proper working of the neurons and the
brain itself
now when they get disturbed
we
get certain conditions which
you know rapidly accelerates the
condition of alzheimer's disorder
so in this data set we have divided our
samples
according to the
table shown below in the
ppt
now
small
information about these
types of variant now these are isogenic
human derived microglial cell lines
the variants are introduced in these
cell lines
and
we see certain type of interesting
things
like the sorel one
micro clear
like cell lines induce trim to
expression which enhance
the apoe expression pathway
now the alzheimer's disorder associated
with sore l1 and trem2 mutations
uh also
impaired the
microglial cell lines
alpha beta uptake in the api dependent
manner in vitro of course
the
cd33 temp2 and sorel one
are all types
one membrane components highly expressed
in the microglial cell lines
when we have to characterize the effects
of alzheimer's disorder associated
variants in the microglial cell line
we
integrated all these mutation into the
h9esc line
by crisper cas9 editing and by v here i
don't mean i
i mean the
scientists who have written the research
paper
now the methodology i have adopted to
study the data set they accomplished is
basically
first of all we have to convert
the tpm values to raw counts
so preparing the raw counts
by
batch filtering and other
and
doing a quantile normalization for them
after that we analyze
all the raw counts and do a pci analysis
for all the different samples and all
the different sets
under different condition we compare
all those
variants separately and together with
the wild type to get a better idea of
what's happening with all those
different variants
then we do a gene ontology and
cake enrichment pathway analysis
which determines the overall direction
and the pathways involved
in the regulation of those
gene samples
now
we derive the volcano plot to find
the
log to fold charge versus the
p adjusted
value plots and then we finally reach to
the conclusion of which type of genes
are being upregulated or down regulated
and furthermore results
now coming on to a pc analysis pipeline
so we have used the
turn for browser provided by our
omixlogic website
to
do all our work and
as shown in the
diagram in the slide we have adopted
this type of pathway to perform our pc
analysis and we provided our raw counts
then we performed a quantile
normalization
and then a pca function was added to it
which was being used
and we got our
results so here are some of the charts i
will not
gloss over them in detail but they are
comparison of
every variant of alzheimer's disorder
with respect to the wild type
so as you can see
here it is
now the interesting part is that we do
not see a very clear demarcation or
grouping in any of these slide except
the trem two
one versus the wild type now in here i
would like to
draw your attention towards the trem2ko
type of variants which is
very different differently grouped from
the trem to our 47h and the wild type
which are grouped together
so that is an interesting founding in
the paper i have written in the results
also and we have worked on that too
now this is a
pta scatter plot from pca scatter plot
for all the variants together
and
you can see that there are two different
grouping here
so yes this is a very significant result
and we have found approximately
we have developed this pca from
a pool of 60 000
sample size genes
after
doing that and getting the pc analysis
done we have performed the differential
gene analysis and the gene ontology
enrichment pathway
we have we have again used this type of
pipeline and the most important thing is
we have kept our p adjacent value of
less than 0.05
and our log to fold change value of
greater than or less than
minus 1
which we have achieved here and we have
reduced our significant gene pool from
60 000 to
less than 1300
and
the
results of
deg analysis are like this and you can
see that most of the pathway which are
activated are like the amino acid
biosynthesis process
these are related to the biosynthesis
and the catalytic processes here
the hormone metabolic process iron
iron iron hematositis and cellular amino
acid metabolism pathway the carbolic
acid or organic acid carboxylic acid
biosynthesis pathway and the
suppressed
paths are like signal transduction and
response to hormone biological adhesions
cell de-differentiation and cellular
developmental process the tube
morphogenesis this type of
pathways are
suppressed here which ultimately
signifies that
there is a
suppression in
like extracellular
linkage between the cells and there is
not a very proper communication or type
of structure which
can support neuron and nervous
conduction
now this is a different
chart here and you can see we have taken
some of the
major significantly affected pathways
here and you can see almost
all the major pathways which are
associated with the alzheimer's disorder
are being suppressed here
now in the volcano plot we have found
out
that
most of the significant genes here
are
significantly reduced in terms of their
expression they are between
minus 2 to minus 4 in terms of log to
full charge
and the p adjacent value is also very
less
this is a second plot which we have
drawn
and we found out that
these eight genes
are very much downregulated and are
considered to be affecting our
alzheimer's
degenerative disorder and lead to very
rapid progression
of alzheimer's disorder and onset of it
in
a very early stage
now uh the conclusion done here was that
the term to loci as we have seen the
pathway which is suppressed and is
related to the structural organization
of the actin fiber
and the sorel one loci generally down
regulates
growth and communication as most of the
pathways suppressed are signal
transaction or
cell proliferation
the inwp 5d loci it usually like down
regulates the
cell repair repairing process and
the proper functioning of the cellular
activities
while it also causes some disruption in
the immunity signaling and causes immune
distress
signal to
propagate within our cortex structure
now this variation all points towards
the
degradation in the condition
from the wild type genes which actually
are
our control group here
and wild type signifies that
of a normal individual so we can clearly
see that these type of variations in the
alzheimer's
uh in the uh microglial cells can induce
alzheimer's disorder
easily and an early onset of it in all
the individuals
so
thank you for listening and these were
the main findings
of our project